hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from round 7 of this
year's Reykjavik open it is a Hungarian
Grandmaster Erdos Victor versus Dina
balenka and you guys requested uh that I
check out this game and it is a a fine
game uh really nice nice quality and uh
yeah interestingly uh Dina's opponent in
this game is rated exactly the same as
the Grand Master she faced uh two rounds
prior to this game 2587 so again a bit
of a rating difference there are almost
300 rating points and uh yeah let's
check out the game it's it's a it's a
very nice one I hope you enjoy it so uh
Victor or uh in this case address Victor
I know if it's Victor Eros or Eros
Victor because everywhere I looked it
says Victor erdog but I read on his
Wikipedia page that Hungarian names are
you know first Elder then Victor so I
guess it's Eros Victor but you guys will
uh correct me if I'm wrong on this so uh
Victor uh goes for E4 and Dina replies
with Pawn to C6 she's for the Karo Khan
defense uh and we have D4 uh standard
way of uh challenging the Karo Khan uh
D5 uh now challenging White Center and
now e captures on D5 The Exchange
variation with C characters and Knight
to F3 uh Knight the C6 by Dina we have
C3 and the position already is quite
rare but the move that Dina plays is uh
has only been played a handful of times
and she plays Queen to C7 standard moves
here are Knight to F6 and Bishop to G4
and are are considered stronger Stephen
Bishop to F5 but she plays Queen to C7
and this is now incredibly incredibly
rare and there are a couple of games
that reach this position Adina also had
it herself in 20 2018 uh she uh faced a
demente cornet in in Saint Petersburg
but she lost that game in that game uh
Queen to B3 was played but here uh we
have Pawn to C4 and it is now as of move
six already that we have a completely
new game so kind of wasting a Tempo but
it is very strong it grabs more space
frees up the C3 Square for the Knight
and the queen being on C7 you really
want your knight on C3 uh to be able to
go to B5 to D5 and so on so the pawn on
D5 is hanging she needs to defend it she
plays Knight to F6 with Knight to C3 and
now Bishop to E6 uh for the moment
blocking your Pawn but uh you know
there's a there's a reason for this uh
Bishop to E3 and now comes Rook to d8
you could also play D catchers and C4
right away but um you you don't have to
of course she plays Rook to d8 uh she
doesn't want to have any uh you know uh
allow white any ideas of maybe you know
capturing and then D forever D5 ever
being an issue and here we have Knight
the G5 here a knight the B5 would be uh
much much trickier if if Knight the B5
attacking the queen uh now if you if you
leave this diagonal then Bishop to F4
becomes very strong so you kind of have
to play Queen to B8 but now look at this
queen to see C1 and already you are
threatening Bishop to F4 and then Knight
the C7 check and it's very very hard to
play this uh you of course can play it
with something like Bishop to G4 uh but
uh you know it's very tricky and you
know white would definitely enjoy a
position like this like a you play A6
you already blunder the game uh but yeah
like some like Bishop to G4 then if the
death for attacking the queen you have
E5 uh that's the point of the G4 freeing
up the uh e file for the pawn and now if
Knight captures an E5 uh threatening
some very nasty discoveries you have
Bishop to B4 with check Knight goes back
to block check and now Bishop back to D6
and now we have a capture Fest C
captress on D5 Knight captures on D4
Knight captress and G4 Bishop captures
an F for attacking the queen here Knight
captures on F6 with check G characters
and queen to D1 now attacks the Knight
Queen to E5 with check and Bishop to E2
and look at this uh complete mess of a
position uh it's uh I mean it would be
impossible to to assess this the engine
says it's perfectly fine for both white
and black of course but the engine says
that about every position uh so that's
why maybe you know not everyone's cup of
tea so a night the G5 was played and now
Bishop to G4 getting the bishop out of
Harm's Way and uh freeing up the path
for the E Pawn to be pushed forward with
F3 challenging the best of Bishop H5 and
now see captures and D5 we have Knight
captures and here Knight captures on D5
Rook captures on D5 and now Bishop the
C4 this is how uh Victor gets his Bishop
into the game with Tempo Rook back to d8
and here he just castles King's side uh
we have H6 kicking the Knight away from
G5 of course the Knight is very strong
though you do not want to check every
move what happens if Knight does this if
Knight does that so it's always best to
just kick the Knight back Knight to H3
and now Pawn to G5 Dina not uh uh you
know worried about any uh King side
expansions her King is still in the
center but uh G5 is definitely a nice
move and also it prevents the knight
from coming to F4 or the Bishop from
coming to F4 so it does quite a lot we
have D5 now challenges the night Bishop
to G7 a very nice in-between move
because the queen is on D1 so you can't
really capture that Knight so Queen to
C1 and now Knight the D4 very nicely
played we have Rook to D1 attacking the
Knight and queen to B6 putting um more
more defense to the to the Knight on D4
and it looks scary putting the queen in
front of the bishop like this but it if
it works you know it works here we have
Ponte A4 trying to chase away the queen
with Ponte A5 but Dina goes Pawn to E5
and now even offers up the uh d-capters
and E6 Alpha Song which Victor does d
captures an E6 Alpha song we have F
characters and E6 and now Knight the F2
the the idea is that if Bishop to B5
checks she wants to play King to F7
that's uh sort of the the safe haven for
the king and then uh The Rook can come
into the game it's sort of artificially
castling uh but I mean castling like
this with no pawns on the seven rank
whatsoever whatever I mean that's that's
pretty awesome stuff so here instead
Knight dev2 was played instead of that
Bishop check and here Dina just castles
I mean in I would say the safety but
this does not look safe at all uh we
rooked the A3 by Victor a nice real
Cliff the bishop is also now guarded
twice by the queen and by The Rook but
also you you can play some like Rook to
C3 Rook to D3 uh many ideas for this um
uh for this uh Rook so here we have King
the h8 and getting the King off of this
diagonal and King to H1 of course Victor
does the same we have Queen to C6 now
she puts pressure on the on the bishop
and C4 uh but also the queen is now on
the same diagonal as the King which is
even more important and here Victor
doesn't realize just how strong this uh
move was and he plays Bishop to D3 and
now he missed something here uh in fact
they both missed something here uh feel
free to pause the video and try to
figure out what white missed by playing
Bishop to D3 while I give you a couple
of seconds
foreign
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this wild
idea and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it's Bishop captures
on F3 it's a free Pawn it's a free pawn
and uh there's no way for white to
punish this um this Pawn grab the
problem is you can never capture if you
capture then just Queen captures on F3
you would check and after King to G1
Queen to H5 this is the tricky winning
move uh and uh not an easy one to find
you have to free up the F3 Square for
the for the Knight and now there's
really not much you can do if Bishop
captures then Bishop coming to D4 is
just brutal uh The Rook is here I mean
there's no way for you to defend this so
after Bishop capture sunny on F3 you
would actually have to trade and then
just Bishop captures and C6 and you're
up a clean Pawn so uh that that was in
the position but uh they both missed it
she played Queen captures and C1 Bishop
captures on C1 root captures and C1 is
better but she played Bishop uh he
played Bishop captures on C1 and now uh
Dina just plays Rook to C8 again they
they both missed this idea of Knight
captures on F3 or maybe they didn't
maybe they just didn't like it point is
that after G captures and Bishop
captures and F3 you nicely connect with
the Rook King to G1 Bishop captures and
Knight captures it seems like okay you
don't have enough because white does
have um uh two pieces for The Rook but
Rook to F3 is very very annoying and now
how do you defend let's say Bishop E2
you have to defend your knight here and
now you can just trade Rook capture
spawn captures and the white spawn
structure is basically non-existent
let's say Bishop to D4 check to
dominated the Knight and it's a very
very strong a strong position for black
so maybe maybe they both saw it and they
didn't like it uh who knows Rook the C8
is what the Dina went for and now we
have Bishop to E4 now he doesn't have to
worry about the F3 Pawn anymore the
bishop now nicely defends that and also
puts pressure on that B7 Pawn so she
plays B6 with Rook to C3 offering a rook
trade and she goes for it Rook captures
with B captures and now Knights the E2
Knight to E2 attacking the bishop and uh
also that pawn is now attacked twice and
here you really have to
uh decide how to how to go about this
position Bishop the B2 is one way to do
it uh he actually decides to give up the
bishop pair which is very very uh very
interesting so C4 uh now he will uh play
A5 at some point maybe create a task
Pawn uh she trades very happily in
Knight captures on C1 we have root
captures on C1 and now Bishop to D4
putting pressure on the Knight but also
keeping around that C5 Square Knight to
D3 and now Rook the C8 and here we have
Pawn to H4 trying to mess up her Pawn
structure on the king side uh this
should be back to E8 goes after the A4
pawn and now Pawn to A5 here you could
consider some other moves but it's not
not not easy to find a move for white
Bishop to B7 is one tricky ideal it's a
rook C7 and Bishop to A6 sort of giving
up the a pawn for for some very very
active moves let's say Bishop captures
on A4 now you play Rook to E1 you go
after the pawn but the problem is after
Bishop to D7 there is no way to to to
grab anything anywhere for example if
rookie 4 attacking the bishop Bishop C3
and now if Knight the E5 which looks
very strong now you will actually trade
Bishop captures Rook captures now you're
putting pressure on the on the king side
but there's Rook to C5 and everything is
nicely defended uh there's really no way
to make anything of this so while while
it is an interesting idea it doesn't
really give white all that much so
instead he goes A5 and now he wants to
mess up her a queen side and her King
side she takes it B captures an A5 it's
a free pawn and also she now has a fast
a pawn but also he has a past C Pawn so
he starts pushing C5 she plays A4 we
have C6 she plays A3 and now Rook the C2
trying to prevent the pawn from reaching
the the A2 light square and now Bishop
captures on C6 it's a very interesting
idea uh but uh I mean it's always funny
the engine wants to play G captures on
H4 and it's like um I mean it's like you
know with a dog and the Bone the dog
must have the bone and it's the same
with the engine and the pond the engine
absolutely must have the pond like it
doesn't matter what's happening the
engine knows if it's uh you know the
winning or or it's a draw but if it's a
pawn the engine will grab the pawn and
here it actually makes sense and you'll
you'll see why later on because you can
always play what the Dina played uh but
you played it now Bishop captures on C6
with Bishop captures and now Rook
captures in C6 the to win the A2 Square
for her Pawn Rook captures on C6 and now
Pawn to A2 now you have to give up The
Rook of course Rook to A6 was played A1
Queen comes with check you capture
Bishop captures and now he plays H
captors and G5 and because of this H
captains and G5 the engine wanted to
grab the pawn on H4 first before
deciding on on this line uh but Okay Age
captures on G5 and now we have this end
game where she's up a pawn it's a
beautiful pass a pawn uh but you know as
I always say Knights are tricky bastards
you've seen in that game that I've
played a couple couple of videos ago I
showed my game also from the Croatian
chess League where I had the end game
where I had a knight against the bishop
and I was also down upon and uh I was
able to to draw the game uh because I
mean it's it's very hard to see all of
the tricks that the Knight can pull off
uh so it's not gonna be easy uh here we
have Knight the C5 maybe again bringing
the king into the game first was a
little bit better and now she has to
decide does she want to give up the E6
Pawn or does she want to defend it she
defended it with Pawn to E5 uh A5 is
also incredibly strong it's in fact
winning but it's uh you have to see a
lot of moves now it captures an E6 A4
Knight the C5 goes after the pawn A3 now
Knight to D3 Bishop to C3 and not Knight
the C1 guarding the the A2 Square You're
Gonna Play Bishop to D4 stop the white
king from entering the game and now
white will have to spend a few moves
pushing those pawns King to G7 King to
G2 now we're gonna play King to F6 uh
Ponte F4 let's say you can even trade
everything captures captures Bishop to
B2 attacked the Knight light the A2 and
knocking the E6 and now the black king
is one tempo uh faster than the white
king king F2 King to D5 you're gonna
play King E2 King C4 King D2 King to B3
and black wins the Knight has no has no
squares you're gonna have to trade them
with some like Knight to C1 check Bishop
captures King captures and now A2 and
all of the squares are taken B1 and B2
are guarded next move you get a queen
and of course the white Pawn is too far
away to be of any significance for this
game so instead she played E5 which is
also a good uh it's it's also in fact
winning is just a different way to do
things uh and now Knights the E4 and
here uh I I think Victor's idea here was
the same as as in my game that I've
shown uh where I was like uh yeah I know
like his position is probably winning uh
if I if I don't grab a pawn but if I
grab a pawn if I equalize material then
I might be winning I might be losing but
you know it's uh it's all it's all I can
do so I I think that maybe this is what
uh Victor also uh thought when he played
this Knights the E4 move uh worth
considering is definitely Knight to A6
just stopping that pawn in its tracks
like not allowing that pawn to go
anywhere and then maybe you try but
still it's a bishop to D4 uh prevents
King G1 and now you start bringing your
king into the game it's uh uh it's still
winning
so instead Knight the E4 was played uh
maybe he you know he he probably said
okay I have to do something he's gonna
grab the pawn and she started pushing A5
Knight captures on G5 with A4 now comes
Knight to E4 and A3 we have Knight to D2
Pawn to A2 and now of course Knight to
B3 attacking the bishop Bishop to D4 and
now Pawn to G3 and here Dina played King
to G7 and this is the a very nice move
uh because you can win the Knight always
captures captures but this is now a draw
because the black king is too far away
and the white king will uh the white
will be able to uh trade off the the
pawns for example King to G2 King to G7
King to F2 you're gonna play something
like Bishop to D4 chocolate taking E2
King to F6 King to D3 and now it doesn't
matter if flaking to F5 just F4 and
um the pawn gets traded off you can't
really push because the bishop hangs so
whatever you're playing
uh will not uh will not be enough you
have to trade pawns here and that's just
80 capture spawn captures like the king
captures King captures and it will be a
draw due to insufficient material so
instead King to G7 this is the way to
win the game uh we have King to G2 and
now King to F6 we have King to F1 and
now only now A1 Queen but now it's very
much different because the king is
already on F6 and not an h8 it's
something uh you know you could find
when you're playing uh for example a
classical game or even a Blitz game it's
something that once you know it exists
it will it will come to you uh you check
a line it doesn't work but the line
actually works just not with your king
and h8 and then you figure okay if my
king is an F on F6 instead then the line
works I I already calculated it so okay
Knight captures on A1 uh we have Bishop
captures and A1 and now King to G2 now
she just has to figure out how to cross
the E4 square if this Pawn can cross the
E4 Square then uh it's easily winning uh
of course you can never push it one as
long as the Pawn is on F3 because once
white captures it will be it will be a
draw so King to F5 with King to H3 now
Bishop to C3 and here King the H4 uh
with Bishop to D2 and now King back to
H3 the problem with King the H5 is that
now you can play Bishop to G5 and you
completely you sort of almost still made
the white king of course the white has
pawn moves and now you can't really do
anything if you play f for uh F4 it
doesn't really matter E4 and now you can
even give up the bishop E3 and there's
really nothing G4 checklist the king to
E6 G6 E2 and now you can even play uh if
Pawn to G7 you just play King F7 you
don't really care so King H6 now E1
Queen and uh well the pawns are are too
far away so that's why he goes back King
to H3 Bishop to E1 and not came to H4
with King to E6 King to G4 not Bishop to
F2 with King to H4 he's just gonna wait
and see if if she can push E4 then okay
it's it's a winning but if she can't
then it's a draw uh King to D5 with King
to H3 and now King to D4 and here we
have Pawn to G4
uh the reason for this Pawn push is that
there's no other move the problem is
that if you play King to H5 then look at
this King E3 and now if you play F4 uh
it's not a problem just e captures on F4
and the the pawn is spin you you can't
capture back and the other move that he
has with the king is King to G2 but now
look at this King E3 uh what do you play
if you move the king you're just gonna
lose this Pawn so you have to play F4
but now E4 and now after F5 you're just
gonna move the bush of the bishop will
nicely control this diagonal or you know
even even this uh and you will not be
able to do anything it's actually a very
fun line so I can show you let's say
King to D3 you have to make way for a
pawn F6 You're Gonna Play Pawn to E3 F7
Bishop has to block the the f8 square G5
You're Gonna Play E2 and now G6 E1 Queen
and not even G7 and it looks uh like you
know white might be pulling off
something but it's actually just a very
nice Force to Checkmate King stage three
Queen F3 check doesn't really matter
what you play you will have to land on a
dark square at some point Bishop D6
checking on Queen to G4 checking to F1
and now Bishop to H2 there's no defense
Queen G1 will be Checkmate and the queen
to E2 will be checking it so if you
promote this Pawn to a queen uh we can
just deliver a nice Queen to G1
Checkmate or if you promote this Pawn to
a queen then a nice Queen to E2 will be
Checkmate so that's why uh the key moves
just don't work this doesn't work this
doesn't work in the G2 also does nothing
just King E3 so that's why he had to
play G4 and already this is a success
for black uh we have uh King to D5 now
it would be very tricky if now instead
of um this King 35 King the E3 is played
then G5 is just very strong because you
you no longer have this diagonal uh to
stop the the pawn the pawn who will
touch the the G7 square and you will not
be able to block it so it would be a
draw so instead Dina goes back King to
D5 now uh uh from D4 King to D5 we have
G5 and now came to E6 we have King to G4
Bishop to E3 and now Pawn to G6 with
King to F6 and now Pawn to G7 as for
lack of a lack of a better move King
captures on G7 and now King to F5 and he
is trying one last trick to save the
game so feel free to pause the video and
don't fall for it while I give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on not playing a
bishop D4 and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is of course
Bishop to F4 the problem is if you play
Bishop D4 then this is just a draw
there's no way to avoid a trade uh if
you put it in just King captures or if
you capture it so it's a it will be a
draw by insufficient material doesn't
really matter what what like plays uh so
uh she of course played Bishop to F4 and
he was in this position unmove 65 that
uh Elders Victor resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
it's it's now it's completely uh winning
it's very easily winning let's say King
G4 came to G6 you're just gonna win some
squares here King G5 King G2 King H4
King F2 King H3 are gonna push back the
white king king F1 King to G3 King E2
and now King G2 and next move you will
win the pawn and that's it King to D3
King captures and now the pawn just
marches forward uh and then becomes a
queen so a very nice Victory by Dina
belenka uh taking down another very
strong Grand Master if you haven't seen
our game
against Gregor so do check it out it
will be the first link in the
description below uh really really
strong attacking game like a really
wonderful attacking game uh if you
haven't seen it you will enjoy it uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it thank you for recommending uh
another nice Victory uh like this and it
is definitely an offset it's almost 300
rating points different so very nicely
done by Dina I would like to wish a very
happy birthday to bhaji and I would like
to thank Marcus Steele Stefan Cornell uh
ravishing reptiles YouTube and Eric
Holtman for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day